cdc director dr richelle wilinski joins
us now with more on the new mass
guidance dr wolinski good morning thanks
for being with us
good morning glad to be here thanks for
having me why was this the right time to
make this decision about
losing masks there were three things
that really helped
make our decision at this moment in time
the first is really in the last two
weeks our cases have come
down by a third so really we have a
rapidly declining case rate probably
because our vaccination rate is going up
second because we now have vaccines that
are widely available
to anybody who wants it if you text your
zip code to 438-829
you can find one of many vaccine sites
that are near you and we now have
enough vaccine and all these sites so
that people are now
empowered to make their own choice about
whether they get vaccinated we have
supply we have availability people are
eligible
and the third is that over the last
several weeks we have had
seen emerging science a growing body of
evidence
that if you are vaccinated you're safe
and protected from
getting coveted 19 and you really have a
very low risk
of transmitting to other people and that
these vaccines are really working
against the variants that we have
circulating here in the united states
okay we we will essentially be relying
on an honor system though
is that in terms of who is vaccinated
and who isn't
uh you won't be able to tell obviously
just by looking at somebody is that an
effective way of
of of doing this you know
what we're really doing is empowering
individuals to make
decisions about their own health so if
you are vaccinated and you are making
the decision to take off your mask then
you've made the decision to get
vaccinated and you are safe
if you are unvaccinated then you have
made the decision to take that risk and
we are really encouraging people who are
unvaccinated
not to take the risk people who are
unvaccinated should not be taking off
their masks
and we're really encouraging them to get
vaccinated as soon as possible
but if you have several people in the
room and some are vaccinated and some
are not and they've all chosen to take
off their masks
it's the vaccinated people who will be
protected right
you talked about this a little bit but
tell me more what do we know
about people who've been vaccinated can
they spread the virus
so um we have now a series of studies
that have been looking
and testing people who are vaccinated
week after week or every other week just
to screen them
the rates of asymptomatic infection are
really extraordinarily low
in those situations not zero but
extraordinarily low
we also know that the these vaccines in
the real world setting have shown 90 to
95 97 percent efficacy yes we are
occasionally seeing infections that
occur in people who are vaccinated
but what we're seeing about those
infections is that they tend to have
a lower amount of virus they tend to be
asymptomatic
they tend to be mild and we believe that
that lower amount of virus really means
that they can't give it to anybody else
all right so so if you see someone who's
been vaccinated who tests positive you
the alarm bells should not be ringing
because
they are for some people yeah you know i
think
we would certainly encourage that person
to put on a mask right we wouldn't
encourage them to be out and about
but what we're learning about those
people is that they're really at lower
risk
of transmitting disease than if they
were unvaccinated well that's
interesting
there are some some vaccinated people
who should
still wear masks who are they and why
you know increasingly we now have some
evidence that suggests that
if you have an immune compromising state
so for
whether due to medicine or to a
background disease so for example
if you are a transplant
recipient and you are on immune
modulating agents for your transplant
then you um their vaccine might not be
working as well as it would for others
if you're on chemotherapy for cancer
your vaccine might not have worked well
as well in others and even if your
dialysis patient your vaccine might not
be as effective as others
so what we would encourage people to do
if they have one of these conditions
is to consult their with their doctor
and say under what conditions would it
be safe for me
to take my my mask off if we end up with
a new variant coming from somewhere
could that change this guidance
i think we have to be humble in this
entire process
we believe that this is the right thing
to do the science has shown us that this
is the right thing to do but we have
always said that we need to keep a close
eye on variants
here's what we know right now currently
right now we are
sequencing about seven to ten percent of
all virus that is
circulating in the united states we now
have that capacity so we have a really
good window
as to the variants that are circulating
here and we will continue to monitor
that carefully what we know in the
science of the variants that are here is
that our vaccines are working against
them
but we really need to make sure as we
continue to monitor what variants are
out there
that our vaccines will continue to work
against them what i can tell you is the
more people who get vaccinated
the less circulating virus we have and
the less likely we will be
to see one of those circulating variants
dr rochelle wilinski thank you again for
being with us this morning we do
appreciate it
thanks for having me